عن جد قصه غريبه بس انا هذا الخبر اللي
هلا رح نقراه هذا انا سعيده جدا
طيب مشاهدينا اكثر كفاءه من الرجال
في الفضاء تخيلوا دراسه نشرت في مجله
اجرها الباحثون في وكاله الفضاء الاوروبيه
هذه هي الدراسه وجدت رائدات الفضاء لديهن
متطلبات اقل في الاحتياج للماء وكذلك
استهلاك الاكسجين وانتاج ثاني اكسيد
الكربون وعمليات التمثيل الغذائي خلال
بعثات استكشاف الفضاء مقارنه
بنظراتهم من الرجال واخيرا استفدنا شيء من
فكره انه انتم بتحرقوه اكثر منا بالفضاء
بهذا اشي ايجابي وراح نبعثكم الى الفضاء
على كل حال مشاهدينا وجدت النتائج ان في
مهمه تستغرق 1080 يوما سيتطلب طاقم مكون
من اربعه افراد فقط من الاناث طعاما اقل
بمقدار نحو 1700 كيلو جرام عما يحتاج
الرجال في نفس المده ما يعني توفير بقيمه
تتجاوز 158 مليون دولار ونحن نتساءل هل
يكون مستقبل الفضاء
للنساء حصرا
والله خبر حلو صراحه خبر حلو
الفضاء ونحن نبقى لوحدنا على الارض
عموما في ثقافتنا نطلق دائما مصطلح امراه
بمئه رجل
النساء
نستطيع على اعتماد عليهن او يعملن في مهن
يسيطر عليها الرجال في اعمال
بناءك حرفيات مثلا في عمل السيارات في
الواقع هذه المجالات تتفوق النساء على
الرجال في العديد من المهن وعلى غرار
مصطلحات الياقات البيضاء
وعمال الياقات البيضاء اللي يشتغلون
باعمالهم اليدويه الحرفيه في ايضا كما
يقال
لياقات الورديه بنك
هي طبعا تطلق على المهن التي تعتبر
مشاهدينا تاريخيا في اعم اي عادل مثل مثلا
التمريض رعايه الاطفال اعمال السكرتاريه
التدريس والعلاقات العامه على فكره يقال
بانه النساء عاده مهتمين اكثر
بالانسان بالناس والرجال يهتموا اكثر
بالاشياء عشان هيك حتى بتلاحظ اختيارهم
للمهن النساء ايضا بروحوا اكثر للمهن اللي
فيها تعامل مع اشخاص اخرين والرجال مثلا
هندسه كذا يتعاملوا باشياء اللي فيها تعب
الرجال يفضلون هم يتطوعون لهذه الاعمال
ويخلون
جسديه اكثر منها
هذا الموقع
وجد انه النساء يكسبون اكثر من الرجال
ب 34 وظيفه بس من اصل 550 وظيفه في
الولايات المتحده يعني يعني النساء هن لهن
التفوق في هذه الوظائف
يعني هم الابرص يعني احنا دائما حتى النص
مش حتى يعني الابرز في نصف عدد الوظائف
البقيه مو معناته ان الرجال متفوقين فيهم
يعني مشوارنا طويل بس احنا خطينا كتير
اصلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات